then Lou Durer was a special education  teacher and baseball coach in New Jersey  known for his goofy sense of humor  looter er was a catcher on his high  school baseball team Don Bosco Prep won  33 straight games on their way to  ranking number one nationally in 2008  looter er went to Marist College on a  baseball scholarship that's where he met  his wife Brandi also a special edy  teacher Lu Durer just opened up with  children his former teammate Dan  slotnick remembered his kindness and his  smile really shone through when he was  with the kids when Lu Durer had  coronavirus symptoms last month  Brandi drove him to the hospital for  treatment he was sent home and seemed to  be improving but then took a turn for  the worse Ben Loutre er was 30  [Music]